permis 14 juillet du quinquennat donc
qu'attendez-vous qu'espéré vos de
françois hollande très franchement plus
grand chose plus grand chose donc c'est
pour ça que cette primaire qui vient de
la droite et du centre est aussi
importante à mes yeux c'est que c'est
l'occasion de recréer un espoir pour les
français
qu'en dire voilà nous arrivons chacun
avec nos projets notre vision de la
france
nos idées à notre méthode de
gouvernement
mais le chef de l'état il a encore des
choses à dire vous allez l'écouter quand
oui il a eu la gentillesse je suis pas
sûr de l'écouté très franchement non non
parce que voilà j'estime que il a menti
il a trompé les français
il n'a pas présenté de vision pas
présenté de cap et que ce quinquennat
est un gigantesque gâchis est donc très
franches proche où il dit moi j'estime
avoir mieux à faire que d'écouter des
paroles creuses des paroles des paroles
des paroles puis derrière pas de
décisions pas d'acte pas de vision du
pays il lui reste onze mois à peu près
au pouvoir et j'espère bien que en mai
prochain mais 2017
mais nous aurons un autre président dans
tous les cas ils pourraient le chef de
l'état encore filer la métaphore
sportive il a fait un peu avant la
finale de l'euro la france a du ressort
elle sait se rassembler on l'a vu contre
ceux qui ne parlent que de ce qui ne
marche pas entraîné un repli ça c'est
pour les leaders de la droite
enfin c'est à l'équipe de france qu'on
doit d'avoir reconnu quelques semaines
merveilleuses vous offert beaucoup de
moments de bonheur c'est pas à françois
hollande
cette façon de récupérer
systématiquement le foot de sport enfin
laissons les sportifs nos amis
footballeurs l'équipe de france là où
elles sont ils nous ont offert
d'excellents moments
mais après il ya la situation de la
france qui reste difficile et d'autres
responsabilités à nous politiques c'est
pas de filets des métaphores toujours un
peu douteuse avec le sport et avec
l'euro de foot c'est de dire voilà les
difficultés des français
voilà les réponses que j apporte et
voilà la parole que je veux tenir pour
que ça marche mieux d'autres pays dans
chaque bonne nouvelle vous savez
ailleurs d'esprit positif
je l'accueille avec beaucoup de plaisir
dès qu'il ya un chômeur en moins
demandeurs d'emploi en moins chez le
premier à me réjouir
enfin je crois
à inverser la courbe du chômage sur la
fin du quinquennat on est bien d'accord
mais c'est pas ce qui compte ce qui
compte c'est pas de se limiter à g
inverser la courbe du chômage et réussi
après avoir créé des centaines de
milliers de chômeurs supplémentaires
finalement inversé la cour enfin ça ça
change pas la situation concrète des
millions de français qui cherchent un
emploi des familles qui s'inquiètent de
ce qu ont plus de 50 ans qui ont été
licenciés et qui retrouve plus rien
l'enjeu n'est pas là l'enjeu c'est de
retrouver un élan pour notre pays donc
pas d'indulgence vohra d'indulgence pour
françois copé il est chef de l'état oui
c'est celui qui a le droit au moins
d'indulgence parce que c'est celui qui a
la fonction la plus élevée donc la
responsabilité la plus élevée alors la
facture sécuritaire mais également celle
des aides diverses aux agriculteurs aux
jeunes aux collectivités locales
également été mise en avant récemment
pour expliquer l'abandon du plan de 50
milliards d'euros d'économies
est ce le signe pour vous d'un manque de
sérieux budgétaire un sérieux qui est
pourtant revendiqué avec force par les
ministres de bercy et notamment michel
sapin je crois surtout que c'est le
signal que à quelques mois d'élections
présidentielles on ouvre tout grand les
vannes de la dépense publique pour
essayer d'acheter les votes de quelques
catégories de population moi je suis
persuadé que les français quel qu'il
soit ne se laisseront pas trompés par ce
genre de décision politique
après ce réduction des dépenses
publiques ce qui compte c'est le sérieux
avec lequel on fait ça c'est l'honnêteté
de ses engagements
dire que l'on va tenir parole et que sur
un calendrier de cinq ans on va tenir sa
ligne de réduction des déficits
mais il s'agit pas de vouloir tailler le
plus possible à l'aveuglé répond je vous
êtes contre la résurgence jeu contre la
purge de la burj fait bien de le
rappeler c'est exactement ça j'arrête la
purge c'est dangereux
et puis ça nous interdire sauf que c'est
parce qu'il a annoncé moi je préfère
annoncer la couleur tout de suite je
serai rigoureux dans la réduction des
dépenses publiques
je tiendrai mon calendrier et mes
engagements mais je ne veux pas imposer
de purges aux français ce que je pense
que c'est pas une bonne solution parce
que je pense que ça ne menaceraient la
croissance
et parce que je pense aussi je les dis à
quelques jours il faut que nous
investissions dans deux domaines majeurs
la justice et les forces arabes
je considère que najat vallaud belkacem
a fait beaucoup de mal à l'éducation
nationale française beaucoup de matches
il a fait beaucoup de mal parce que elle
a supprimé le mérite en supprimant les
bourses au mérite
elle a fait beaucoup de mal en nivelant
par le bas et en supprimant ce qui
marchait par exemple les classes
bilangues elle a fait beaucoup de mal en
développement l'égalitarisme zend et
tout le monde doit avoir deux langues
étrangères au collège en cinquième alors
qu'on sait que des dizaines de milliers
de gamins qui rentrent en sixième sans
parler correctement le français elle a
fait beaucoup de mal
en nous disant qu'il fallait que les
enfants apprennent l'arabe au cp moi je
considère qu'en france dans l'école de
la république c'est la langue française
que l'on apprend au cpl a fait beaucoup
de mal en prêchant pour des recrutements
tous azimuts alors que je maintiens que
aujourd'hui on continue à avoir du mal à
recruter des 100 saignant de qualité de
bon niveau et qu'on dévalorise les
enseignants qui sont actuellement en
poste en recrutant d'autres enseignants
qui n'ont pas forcément le même niveau
et je pense que fondamentalement ce
développement de la culture de
l'égalitarisme du nivellement par le bas
cette révision des programmes d'histoire
la manière qu'elle a eue de supprimer l'
apprentissage sérieux du latin pour moi
c'est un zéro pointé
je pense vraiment sincèrement plus
profond de moi-même que najat vallaud
belkacem a fait beaucoup de mal à
l'éducation nationale française et que
l'un des défis pour nous quand nous
reprendrons le pouvoir en 2017 ce sera
de restaurer le mérite
l'apprentissage de la langue française
la chronologie dans l'histoire un
collège diversifié plutôt qu'un collège
unique
le refus du nivellement par le bas et de
l'égalitarisme au bénéfice du mérite
cette un enjeu majeur pour 2017
vous avez été ministre d'agriculture une
polémique se développe en ce moment
autour de la nomination possible du
directeur de cabinet de stéphane le foll
à la tête de l'inra monsieur philippe
mauguin est ce que vous êtes vous même
choqué par cette perspective là je
demande à françois hollande de renoncer
à cette nomination
l'inra c'est un des instituts de
recherche agronomique les plus pointus
les plus prestigieux au monde une bonne
procédure de nomination serait non pas
le fait du prince comme c'est le cas
actuellement
un mini schiro case son premier
collaborateur
mais le processus de domination dans
lequel on aurait un appel
candidature avec des projets clairement
défini scientifique des projets de
développement de l'inra ou un collège
d'experts pourrait donner son avis y
compris d'ailleurs avec des experts
internationaux ce que je pense que pour
un organisme aussi prestigieux que
l'inra ce serait bien d'avoir un regard
international et qu'à la fin le meilleur
projet le meilleur candidat soit retenue
mais le fait du prince en matière de
domination ça me choque profondément
je souhaite que françois hollande
renonce à cette nomination qui fait
honte à la république et qui de la part
d'un président de la république qui
avait dit que sa présidence serait
exemplaire est un nouveau monument
c'est une tâche ce sera une tâche si
c'était fait ce serait une tâche par
rapport aux engagements qu'il a pris
françois hollande qui nous avait dit
pendant le discours de bourget puis
pendant toute sa campagne de 2012 je
serai un président qui rétablira la
république exemplaire le fait du prince
dans les nominations ce n'est pas la
république exemplaire une question sur
emmanuel macron bien sûr qui est en
meeting ce soir à paris monté sur une
estrade doit t il selon vous l'amener à
quitter le gouvernement et au plus vite
il fera son choix dans tout cas il faut
qu'ils tranchent et un moment donné en
politique il faut trancher à l'un et
l'autre c'est pas d'un vélo c'est pas le
gouvernement et la campagne la campagne
et le gouvernement
c'est l'un ou l'autre à lui 30 noms mais
est-ce que vous vous sentez des
affinités avec lui veut rassembler les
progressistes de droite et de gauche
entre les galets les gens qui se
retrouvent de droite et de gauche sur je
crois pas en cet
et oui il va pas du tout et cette
confusion à cette gauche manière de dire
voilà il ya plus de différence c'est la
différence c'est des propositions qui
sont pas les mêmes on vient de parler de
collèges d'éducation voyez bien peu
propositions sont à l'opposé de celle de
najat vallaud belkacem et c'est très
bien comme ça je le dis sereinement
je le dis de manière constructive ayons
ce débat et que les électeurs tranche
mais si tout se vaut plus rien ne se
vaut donc attention à cette façon de
mélanger de brouiller les lignes et de
dire qu'on va mettre avec soin tous les
progressistes que ça veut absolument
rien dire c'est de la soupe
gresso où c'est la soupe la politique a
besoin de clarté la beaujoire ont fait
de la soupe
ben pour l'instant tout ce que j'entends
oui c'est de la soupe
le 2 juillet dernier monsieur sarkozy
qui est donc le président du parti des
républicains a rassemblé un conseil
national pour présenter le projet du
parti
vous n'étiez pas là les seuls absents
vous l'avez fait exprès on imagine je
leur absence
là des gens me connaissent et j'assume
mes choix bon alors je ne sais pas que
je les fais je les jeux les médias
michel grossiord je ne me sens pas
engagé et je crois à la clarté en
politique je pense que là aussi les
français en ont ras le bol la confusion
des jeux politiciens des petites
alliance puis je suis là mais je suis
pas vraiment là je viens mais je viens
pas vraiment je prends la parole
maintenant moi ce n'est pas mon projet
donc je ne viens pas je respecte ce
projet je le slim qu'il ya un bon
travail qui a été fait il ya des choses
et quelques chants d accord complet
enfin je vais pas venir soutenir un
projet dont la première mesure c'est le
rétablissement du cumul des mandats en
enfin vous nous voyez venir devant les
français et de leur dire à vous français
vous allez changer mais nous les
responsables politiques
il est hors de question qu'on change et
même on va rétablir le cumul des mandats
ça regarde bien les gars qu'est ce que
vous leur reprochez à tous les projets
de vos concurrents
d'abord c'est une question essentielle
le cumul des mandats question symbolique
commencer le prochain quinquennat en
disant nous allons protéger à nouveau
les élus et rétablir le cumul des
mandats je pense que celle inverse de ce
qu'attendent les français et celle
inverse de ce que jean ferrat vitesse
viable si j'ose dire
et ceux qui sont pour le rétablissement
du cumul donc les sarkozystes monsieur
sarkozy en tête ne disent pas on va
protéger les nôtres ils disent il vaut
mieux avoir un pied dedans et un pied
dehors quand on fait de la politique
autrement dit quand on est parlementaire
c'est bien aussi d'avoir un pied à
l'étrier sur place au niveau sur le
terrain
sur le terrain ce n'est pas sur le
terrain cotto n'est pas l'enfant terre
on n'est pas sur le terrain c'est une
drôle de conception du parlementaire le
député il est élu au suffrage universel
direct par des citoyens est en contact
et que ses citoyens
tous ces arguments sont des prétextes
des prétextes pour maintenir son pouvoir
pour maintenir les baronnies pour
maintenir les fiefs moi je ne crois pas
au cumul des mandats je pense qu'il faut
limiter le nombre de mandats dans le
temps des députés des sénateurs
je pense qu'il va durer de venir dans
deux députés du président du président
réduire le nombre de sénateurs est
obligé tous nos hauts fonctionnaires qui
font de la politique a démissionné de la
fonction publique quant à votre question
qu'elle a dit fait
la différence c'est que moi je n'ai
jamais présenté de projet aux français
en 2007
il ya un très beau projet qui était
présenté aux français le drame c'est
qu'il n'a pas été appliquée l'une des
premières mesures c'était la tva sociale
au bout de trois semaines après
l'élection présidentielle de 2007
exit la tva sociale la deuxième mesure
c'était le contrat de travail unique au
bout de deux mois exit le conte à la
lune et à l'arrêter il a et l'a fait à
la fin de son quinquennat à mieux quand
on propose quelque chose et aux golfeurs
au début parce que sinon quand on le
fait à la fin il ya le risque d'être
battu de pas pouvoir l'appliquer
c'est ce qui s'est passé là vous avez
bien vu c'est sarkozy c'est bien pour ça
là aussi toutes les explications
possibles ce que je constate c'est qu'il
ya une déception que le projet n'a pas
été appliquée eh ben mon engagement
c'est justement de tenir parole sur le
projet crise était très mordant à vous
écouter on a l'impression que nicolas
sarkozy par nature est disqualifié mais
il a un bilan donc il ne peut plus
revenir
michel brochure c'est important de
présenter les choses clairement aux
français c'est un problème vous désirez
oui mais je pense que ça devrait
peut-être des choses à dire sur alain
juppé alors du même tonneau
il ya des différences dans nos projets
oui des différences importantes
alain juppé propose de faire un mandat
unique c'est un des arguments phares il
nous dit voilà je ferai un mandat unique
c'est l'assurance que je ferai les
choses
je crois au contraire que le quinquennat
unique c'est une impasse que ça conduira
à un président faible et qu'un président
fait ne peut pas faire de grand chose
les parrainages c'est difficile pour
tout le monde ça a été difficile pour
moi j'y ai consacré un temps avec mes
équipes et je rends hommage à mes
équipes absolument considérable mais
pour avoir ces parrainages
il faut voir un projet qui puisse
mériter et susciter le soutien des
parents nathalie mme kosciusko morizet
n'a peut-être pas je souhaite le
nathalie kosciusko morizet soit
candidate et j simplement que chacun est
face à ses responsabilités
les parrainages trop les parrainages de
150 élus et 2500 adhérents
est ce qu'on a mis la barre trop haut on
peut pas dire tout et son contraire à
cotonou dit à trop de candidats
l'apprend nous dit la barrière et rod
parfois elle savoir
moi j'estime que la barrière a été fixé
par notre famille politique que c'est
quelque chose qui est juste et
nécessaire pour éviter la dispersion des
candidats après moi je souhaite bonne
chance à nathalie kosciusko
reese et je souhaite sincèrement qu'elle
puisse être candidat très bonne chance à
nadine morano
j'espère qu'il y aura des candidates
féminines à cette primaire je devrais de
vraiment au plus profond de moi même et
je crois que si ça n'était pas le cas ce
sera vraiment la preuve que notre
famille politique a du mal à se
renouveler et qu'il reste encore un
sacré boulot à faire alors la
déclaration de candidature de monsieur
sarkozy balaie attendue vers la fin du
mois d'août ou plus exactement le 25
août au plus tard c'est la date couperet
il a raison de ce d'attendre le dernier
mot famille à côté de pas sur moi pour
aller commenté des campagnes d autres
déjà suffisamment à faire avec ma propre
campagne
voyez bien vous me dites vous même il
faut que je passe d' outsider à gagnant
avec mes équipes etc mais parlementaire
avec tous ceux qui me soutiennent
partout à travers la france c'est notre
seule ambition apporter cette générosité
cet enthousiasme pour montrer que le
renouveau est possible et que ce n'est
pas comme le dit david revault
d'allonnes voilà ça y est il est lui
déjà le résultat c'est très bien d'être
aussi clair et aussi net que les
journalistes leçon pourquoi les choses à
y serait la liberté de parole il fallait
responsables politiques lui vous donne
cinq mois al avance le résultat la
primaire le maire sera montebourg il
fera un gros score on n'en attendait pas
un gros score un assez gros score et
c'est quoi il y les lecteurs à lui tout
seul de tous les électeurs de la droite
du sang de tous ses sympathisants qui ne
veulent plus de françois hollande
moi je crois au peuple français je crois
sa capacité de révolte
je crois sa volonté de tourner la page
je crois sa volonté d'inventer quelque
chose est de reconstruire quelque chose
de nouveau de 9 pour la france
vous verrez la surprise que les
électeurs réserveront les 20 et 27
novembre
je le sens dans tous les déplacements
que je fais alors les français ont hâte
hâte de passer à autre chose
josé manuel barroso at il commis une
faute contre l'europe
oui oui faux pas contre l'europe la
commune une faute contre les principes
les plus élémentaires de la morale
politique
le mélange des gens quand on était
président de la commission doit pas
travailler pour une banque dont on sait
qu'elle a falsifié les comptes grecs
alors même qu'on était responsable à la
crise grecque c'est un principe
élémentaire de dignité politique
il a comme une voûte il doit partir il
doit démissionner de cette fonction
aujourd'hui c'est à lui de voir quelle
conséquence ils en tireront vous me
demandez mon regard mon regard est très
simple josé manuel barosso a commis une
faute
si vous prenez des engagements aussi à
jour vous deviez quitter la politique
est ce que vous vous engagez elle ne
jamais travailler pour une banque
d'affaires
nous n'en sommes pas là mais je dois
dire que contrairement à d'autres moi
j'ai jamais eu beaucoup d'appétence pour
la banque d'affaires c'est un métier que
je respecte et qui est très important
d'ailleurs pour financer notre économie
mais voilà c'est pas mon truc
moi je ne vois pas banquier d'affaires
vous souhaitez augmenter le budget de la
défense pour le porter à environ 2 % du
budget national
alain juppé a dit je vous le dis je le
cite
il ne sert à rien de promettre des
augmentations et réaliste vous est
irréaliste
c'est dommage peut être ambitieux pour
la france et on peut c'est dommage on
peut tous être ambitieux en affichant
une image cette espèce de résignation
avoir des forces armées qui n'ont ni les
équipements ni les hommes ni les
technologies dont elles ont besoin
cet acharnement à gérer promet marc et
ankara c'est dommage de ne pas voir que
tout autour de nous la russie se
réarment la chine se réarment notre
environnement immédiat et dangereux en
particulier au moyen-orient
et bien moi j'en tire les conséquences
et jeudi de manière réaliste les
responsables il est temps d'en finir
avec trente années on a cessé de réduire
les budgets et l'équipement de nos
forces armées pour leur donner enfin les
moyens nous protéger vous cherchez des
différences de fond avec un à juppé en
voilà une
lui estime qu' il faut colmater les
brèches ici ou là et bien moi j'estime
qu'en matière de défense
au contraire il faut réinventer un
modèle d'armée qu'ils soient plus
efficaces
technologiquement plus avancés capable
de mieux nous protéger
quant aux armées sont fortes la nation
française est forte c'est mon ambition
est notamment à la gp n'est pas assez
fort sur ce thème là sur le thème
régalien je l'entends dire que ça n'est
pas responsable ou pas réaliste de
proposer 2 % pour le budget militaire de
la nation française dans le 15 décembre
aux travaux très chiant 16h10 en danger
disions que cette proposition est
responsable réaliste est nécessaire deux
exemples encore si vous me permettez
est-ce qu'il faut repasser le charles de
gaulle
signe qu'il faut un deuxième porte
avions je vais vous dire pourquoi le
charles-de-gaulle va rentrer en arrêt
technique majeur son troisième arrêt
technique d'ici quelques temps il va
être immobilisé pendant une période de
dix-huit à vingt mois c'est à dire que
pendant 18 à 20 mois la france n'aura
pas de groupe aéronaval ne pourra pas
projeter sa puissance et faire les
démonstrations de force qui peuvent être
nécessaires leur choix on a un groupe
aéronaval
soit on en a pas on en a pas un qui est
à disposition uniquement quand le porte
avions n'est pas en réparation donc je
propose de lancer dès 2017
les travaux et les études pour la
réalisation d'un 2
deuxième porte avions de façon à ce que
la france puisse disposer à tout moment
d'un groupe aéronaval qu'elle puisse
projeter en fonction de la menace